let's read this first story
the most important story from fox
business
elon musk sends poop emoji to twitter
ceo in response to thread on spam and
fake accounts
twitter has estimated that spam and fake
accounts make up less than five percent
of the social media platforms users okay
i had to lead with the poop emoji one
but the real story is that elon musk
may actually
a deal at a lower price is not out of
the question there's a lot to break down
in this story but basically
elon musk tweeted out a story from may
2nd
where twitter filed a report saying
their users was around five five percent
of their users were spam or bots
elon musk the deal was on hold until he
could verify that today the ceo said you
can't verify it because we have internal
data on who people actually are and it's
private that we can't share that's an
interesting point elon mentioned that he
would take a random sampling of 100
users
and then he got accused of like that's a
ridiculous sample size you can't use
that so then he revealed actually this
is
twitter is that's the number they use
then twitter apparently called him or so
he says and accuse him of violating his
nda things are getting crazy i'm not
entirely convinced the deal will go
through my personal opinion is that elon
musk is intending to expose algorithmic
manipulation and potential fraud as it
pertains to bots two things we ended up
learning since this
this deal was going through one
twitter misrepresented its user accounts
by i think a couple million on more than
one occasion even the verge question how
could that have happened and then we saw
the strange shift where people
associated with the right libertarians
started gaining tons of followers
particularly people who were associated
with like marjorie taylor green or matt
gates gained a ton but then we saw
barack obama lose a bit we saw katy
perry lose a bit if you were associated
with with the mainstream or the left you
were losing followers now to me my
theory is algorithmic manipulation but
i'm curious what your guys's thoughts
are i don't know matt i mean i think
when it comes to that i think people are
just uh reacting to the news of elon
musk i think people heard what elon musk
was planning to do in terms of bringing
back ben users specifically one donald
trump and i think you had a number of uh
people who lean left or maybe apolitical
but just don't like donald trump or
people of that uh you know of that
political affiliation
um and they
deactivated their account i'm not even
saying they left for good they just
deactivated as a as a protest and um you
know conservatives definitely came back
because they heard elon musk and you
said this a lot conservatives
actually think and i can't say all but
the ones that you see on twitter
randomly like you saw all these uh big
conservative like influencers come on
and go like oh i'm back because elon
musk and it's like why are you lying to
your followers that's not true you're
not back with elon musk because elon
musk didn't do anything he doesn't own
twitter yet like they came back well you
had tucker carlson act like he came back
because he was no he was suspended i
think he was suspended and he acted he
acted like he he could have unsuspended
himself at any time he had to delete a
single tweet he chose on the day that
elon musk
announced he was going to purchase all
that news came out about ilamas elon
musk purchasing twitter he decided on
that day to tweet that uh i'm back there
were a few others uh who said that too i
can look them up in a second if you want
for sure i'm familiar with it yeah and
it's like why are you because they know
like tucker carlson knows because he did
what charlie kirk's another one um they
he said he was back he he said he was
back on twitter he had to delete a tweet
oh right right right because they they
all had tweeted something that goes
against twitter's policy but hold on so
so right so did they delete the tweets
or they reinstated no they deleted the
tweets do you know that for sure i know
that for sure do you know who the
red-headed libertarian is i'm not
familiar with the russians she's my
go-to example of this one she was
suspended in january of 2021 for no
reason right like she didn't break any
rules
they didn't tell her why she was
suspended but she got reinstated the
following day
sure there were a whole bunch of people
that um you know that that we saw who
were saying things like i was suspended
until now we had people chatting us like
i haven't been on twitter because i've
been banned let me check whoa my
account's back well do they know that it
was back before that for all they know
that suspension could have lifted in the
next months before yeah
it's possible it's anecdotal right but
we do know we do know that those big
influencers who could have deleted they
weren't suspended and had nothing they
could do to get back on they
specifically were told delete this
offending uh the policy that offends our
the tweet that offends our policy excuse
me delete that and you can come back on
that's the rule for certain uh content
that goes against their policy it's not
a full-blown suspension and they could
have done it any time chose not to and
the day elon musk and you know the news
broke uh he based they basically came
back and decided but you know i i don't
think you can say you know that tucker
deleted the tweet the tweet's not there
anymore if maybe they deleted it no they
don't do that they don't do that for
that okay occasionally i i i would agree
too it does sound like they deleted the
tweet they definitely came back i mean
maybe but maybe like it's like you're
saying people joined the platform
because elon was moving in so they were
like okay i'll come back now yeah they
chose to maybe now decide to delete the
tweet sure that could be one occasion
here's the challenge i i have with with
this idea i mean i think
uh we we've talked about it quite a bit
i think fraud and the reason is on the
surface that makes the most sense
twitter said
uh people deactivating their accounts
was organic and and uh i don't think
they i don't know if they commented on
people signing up or joining but when
you take a i pulled up my twitter
numbers here we can see that on april
25th
i gained 19 000 on april 27th i gained
39 000 on the 28th 47 000. it's crazy
but on monday the day that the news
actually broke i only gained i only
gained a thousand it was eight a.m right
why did no one sign up on the day of and
why did they wait to 24 hours after that
i've got no idea i mean there's
something certainly interesting going on
at twitter right now and i've i you know
i don't think anyone could really
explain it why did katy perry lose 200
000 followers right well i'm sure she
has a user base that's
mainly young millennial gen z and you
know we know from a fac uh you know that
they're not big fans of donald trump why
why the following monday did twitter put
out its report on its total numbers of
bots and spam the week before we have
this weird thing happen a day after the
sale is announced so you know here
here's my train of thought i don't i
don't think you're you're wrong i think
what i see as being more probable is
monday at 8 a.m they announced they're
in the final discussion
nothing happens it was it was at 2 53
p.m i think they officially announced
that elon 52 maybe had officially
secured the deal
that night something changed so the next
morning
massive growth of followers tons of
people you know like aside from tucker
and other people who are like on
suspension to remove a tweet there were
people who were saying that they were
banned and the example that i go to and
again it's anecdotal it's not you know
like more than that the redheaded
libertarian who had created a new
account was banned and we don't know why
all of a sudden getting reinstated a
year later but 24 hours after the fact
the drop-off in in followers was the
same thing 24 hours after so i'd imagine
that the morning they announced elon
musk was going to buy the platform
people would have started signing up and
coming back right maybe i mean i i
really i don't think either of us could
really speak to this we just only
speculate i mean because there could
have been things happening behind the
scenes at twitter um there could be
external factors where third parties
decided to literally manipulate it so
that people like you and me would sit
here and pontificate about what could
possibly have happened um i mean we just
don't know that's one of the you know
that's one of the issues and you know i
think the the uh in terms of this
particular story i think the bigger
thing here is you know elon musk knew
this information like he he announced
that reuters like he shared that reuters
story
about the ten percent less than ten
percent of uh less than five percent was
five i'm pretty sure it was ten five
that might be five okay uh whatever the
percentage was i got axios well under
five percent okay so he had that
information that under five percent uh
were spam
uh but the reuters story he shared
that's from the twitter filing that he
had already in the prior week or two
when he announced he was gonna buy
twitter like he knew this he had their
filing before they filed he he knew no
he knew the information he was let in
obviously on what
he had to make a decision on whether to
buy the company or not so they would let
him they would let them know what their
projections are or what their you know
what their their finances where
where did you hear that well they would
it's part of the it's part of the deal
that's where it's from it's it's like
it's in the it's in the deal itself it
says that we gave elon information on
these things he had all he had a bunch
of information how he makes the info
that's how he makes the determination to
buy the company sounds like he didn't
have that information that's why he's
raising an issue i mean perhaps i mean
it's weird that he would you know it's
weird that he would go about doing this
and then because me personally i thought
you know a lot of people were worried
that elon musk would um you know change
twitter and that's what you know that's
why people left and that's why there was
all this i don't i'm not worried about
twitter uh in terms of elon musk doing
horrible things to like content
moderation like maybe he will maybe he
won't i think he's just mostly a hype
man he likes the attention he likes to
say a lot of things and not you know and
not deliver um i think the biggest
threat to twitter when it comes to elon
musk is he seems to not understand
social media he doesn't understand the
business of social media at all if you
look at his ideas to generate revenue he
wants users to pay to use twitter it's
not going to happen well i think he said
high profile users so if individuals
using twitter would not have to pay for
it but if you were a larger brand or a
government you would have to pay some
kind of fee well i would definitely do
that i mean maybe you would but there's
also a lot of companies that just
wouldn't oh
basic like users who would be
influential like the idea that everyone
who's uh who's got a blue check mark or
anyone who's got a lot of followers is
automatically someone of means or
something like that it's just three
bucks month just for i mean three
dollars people people wouldn't you
people wouldn't pay people wouldn't i i
think they would i mean the what he's
talking about is a suite of tools and
access to fix problems and to help the
high profile customers i think he's
right um i think if you look at
uh most digital services they offer a
hey if you know you pay this premium
package we'll give you access to this
these back-end tools these analytics and
things like that like we pay for a bunch
of google tools like i have multiple
google reps for all the different stuff
we use we have nothing like that for
twitter i've even bought twitter ads and
there's like no one to talk to right
because twitter users don't necessarily
uh react to twitter ads it's not the
same business model oh they do they do i
got a million hits on my song by putting
it by buying an ad for it right for real
no but there's there's all sorts of
different types of advertisements i mean
just look at twitter's revenue it's
nowhere near the amount that you know
facebook or google makes it's just not
the same audience they just do when
you're making the case for elon how many
companies being run really bad oh no no
no doubt about it yeah twitter twitter i
was talking about this with someone
earlier uh in terms of the big tech
companies twitter was the most
susceptible to something like this um
you know elon can't afford google
exactly or you know and can't afford
facebook he can't afford you know any
apple amazon microsoft they're well
beyond the amount he could he could
barely even do twitter he needs to bring
a whole bunch of people on board uh i
need to sell he needs to sell tesla
stock um but but it was the
it's the one
um platform that's in this realm
that has the same sort of cachet as
those other platforms like when you
think of the big tech platforms you
throw twitter in there even though
they're nowhere near as big when you
look behind the curtain they're the most
important though
in a sense in a sense it's the depending
on what your niche is depending what
your industry is
in terms of media and news for sure but
i'm sure if you talk to people outside
those industries again we're in this
bubble here so to us we probably i mean
i use twitter more than anything else
too yeah um we're definitely in a bubble
i think that's a problem with a lot of
things going on people are in a bubble
and they don't realize that they're
basically you know just taking
information as they see it through their
own lens and there's whole other worlds
on other platforms even on twitter
there's whole other worlds that you
probably don't don't even know who tim
poole is period oh for sure yeah yeah
i've i've tracked the there's a really
cool mapping thing they do they've made
multiple where it shows you like the
different universes on twitter and how
they can connect and some don't there's
like a cluster of people that's really
small that has zero connection to the
rest of the platform in any way and it's
the weirdest thing and i i've seen one
where there's like a couple of users and
i'm just like what are they talking we
need to figure out what they're doing
what are they doing over there by
themselves uh i think though it's it's
the most important because
it is uh it's the town square facebook
isn't facebook is oh that's what twitter
brands itself as for sure right so so
twitter is you know news stories they
got you tim no they do no they for sure
um i mean i started on twitter because
of occupying it was a way to get news
out really quick and because
people who do news and politics use it
it's become influential in the space of
neutral politics and because it is
that's why you unwanted libs of tick
tock is setting policy
now cool no for sure i mean
they repost these videos and all of a
sudden it's impacting laws in other
states so twitter facebook doesn't do
that right youtube i mean they'll do it
a little bit because they're information
platforms that have influence but
twitter man i mean so so many have
argued this i mean people people at
corporate press facebook does
disseminate information to people who'd
be more likely to um believe in
something they read online based on you
know
it being falsified or you know not
factual um simply because they seem to
be
the more common everyday uh user in
terms of like
your parents yeah your parents are on
facebook you know family members use
facebook for all sorts of different
reasons and people share things on
facebook that uh you know they just sort
of passively read or or uh you know uh
take in and they just shared people that
follow them on facebook well and i think
you kind of hit the nail on the head
there when you discussed family
specifically a huge part of why people
use facebook based on my own experience
and the reason people use instagram is
because they're keeping in touch with
people around them whereas with
platforms like twitter and youtube yeah
they're also social media platforms but
they're much more about seeking
information from complete strangers or
people who you've come to trust over the
years because you like their you know
angle on things sure yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time